et ces maisons bon soir bon ça comment
ça va on s'est vus khwaja il ya non
juste ouais c'est à l'époque c'était la
[ __ ] de la république il ya eu de
l'oci qui a passé maintenant ça
s'appelle l'opération bravo et sur
christine bravo
je croyais que c'était opération
alors vous dites d'ailleurs maintenant
parlons de votre livre la [ __ ] ma
public j'aurais mieux fait de l'appeler
[ __ ] république ouais c'était pas mal
aussi comme si c'était pas mal mais
j'avais hésité à l'époque josé pas
encore bon et plein de choses que
j'osais pas faire encore alors ils sont
dépassés des choses ouais alors on va y
aller
comment vous avez d'avaloirs pour ce
livre là
jeudi par mois je vais faire si on joue
pas je vais le dire elle vit un million
un peu moins quand vous êtes très mal
informé trois livres en maintenant c'est
beaucoup il faut faire de la com offert
des bouquets alors vous revenez ce soir
et vous me dites d'une certaine façon
parce que j'ai vu votre bouquin vous me
dites chérie je vous ai menti ah oui je
vous ai menti mais il ya un an moi je
vous croyais non mais vraiment non mais
sérieusement c'est qu'on m'a reproché on
m'a dit beaucoup de gens m'ont dit ward
y sont c'est vachement bien et avec
elles tu a fondu complètement mes jouets
mais il faut la comprendre la pauvre
tout ça est maintenant je m'aperçoive me
raconter des histoires c'est terrible
j'vois pas que des histoires de trois
points qu'on verra mais non dans ce
livre je dis pourquoi j'aime en ont
marre projet devrait être sympa avec
vous il ya elle ce qu'a voulu me faire
un procès parce que j'avais dit
voilà un cas précis on fait le soir 60
hans afin de vous coûter 300 mille
balles la plaisanterie j'aurais été
obligé d'écrire un livre ouais
alors on parlait de janvier le kawbab
tout à l'heure avec pierre botton il
vous a bien étrillé sur europe1 l'autre
matin pourquoi pour vous à votre avis il
a été de si méchants les goûts je pense
qu'à certaines je sais pas je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses importantes
et des vérités qui font mal quelquefois
et puis on qui supporte pas oui et puis
on voudrait que j'arrête de parler et
d'écrire
alors les médias ont commencé par
accueillir votre livre je dirais un peu
du bout des lèvres un peu avec des
pincettes et d'un nouvel observateur
airy routier qui est un très très bon
journaliste qui connaît en plus la
sphère elle puisqu'il a écrit forages en
eaux profondes
avec valérie lecasble et routier dit et
si madame de viège en cours avait cessé
de mentir il donne un certain nombre
d'arguments
trouvant d'une certaine façon alors là
vous avez pas me le refaire le coup me
regardez pas comme ça que j'ai interdit
de me regardez pas ce que je vais encore
craqué et puis à chaque fois je ferai je
me fais engueuler meilleures séries
quelques rien qui a été trop sympa avec
pour coiffer remis ça avec dumas non
parce que maintenant j'ai dit toute la
vérité mais vous savez ça fait un moment
que j'ai à dire on oublie ça fait quand
même depuis le printemps dernier gtk
vérité moi bien faire tous les cas c'est
un peu comme le livre de pierre botton
et les sorties depuis une semaine ya pas
eu de plaintes 1
personne vous attaquez ravi parce que
c'est la preuve que je ne monte pas
parce que si je cite pas mal le jour là
de temps richesse et si vraiment aidé
des détails des gens et si vraiment je
monte je pense que depuis une semaine il
ya plein de gens qui seront montés au
créneau en 10 ans allemand s'est parée
pour l'instant c'est le silence c'est
plutôt bien c'est ça tombe bien ça a
créé dit me dire quand vous connaissez
la faire
je voulais vous refaire un jeu vous
faire un résumé de la sphère en question
et se permettait à nos amis
téléspectateurs ça parle d'une chanson
c'est la peinture achat sur tout ça et
puis après je sais pas ce que
laisse toi avec jean-jacques de moules
tout apprécié plus j'ai décroché moi
j'étais là maintenant je deviens de
chasseurs exactement alors je répète je
rappelle la faire pour ce qu'ils l'aient
oublié dans thomson veut vendre de
l'armement à taiwan qui a dit rex
formose chine nationaliste six frégates
pour se protéger de la chine communiste
de pékin voile à taiwan c'est une toute
petite île dont ils ont besoin d'avoir
des armes jusque là c'est clair ouais
j'ai compris
après mais à cause du gouvernement
français le groupe français dit non on
va pas vendre d'armes à taiwan puisque
nous on est ami avec la chine communiste
avec la chine voilà thomson se dit la
légende thompson son marchand d'armes se
disent on va utiliser le réseau elf qui
est parce que je suis encore me faire
condamner mais elle s'est pas seulement
de l'essence qui a aussi des raisons et
les cendriers et les verts
je m'économise 300 mille fois
mille trois cent mille francs est alors
votre patron donc enfin votre amie à
l'époque alfred sirven qui était un
numéro de francs patron et ami numéro 2
de deux elfes à l'époque dirigé par loïk
le floch prigent bas ils vous demandent
d'influencé roland dumas jusque là c'est
clair que l'on sait ça veut dire quoi
c'est pas tout à fait l'histoire mais
c'est pas méchant c'est en tout cas pas
influencer moi j'essaie
aujourd'hui
comme ça à l'époque on avait la carte de
crédit de sagesse et sa ba ouais vous
avez bon goût un taux bas donc roland
dur à l'époque
je suis et je serai jamais ta bulle et
j'ai pas vu mais j écoute pierre parent
et des biens
roland dumas à l'époque donc été mise
féministe et anne-lise affaires
étrangères c'était votre amant et vous
êtes chargé de l'influencé que le
gouvernement français acceptent qu'on
vende des frégates à taïwan même si
c'est pas exactement ça c'est terrible
parce qu'on dit c'était mon amant
l'époque c'était ma vie privée qui
aurait jamais dû se savoir y avait mon
travail et ma vie privée avec le malheur
pour moi c'est que toutes ces bélanger
et que ça a mal fini voilà bien alors
pour faire sauter le veto du
gouvernement français on vous demande
d'influencé roland dumas en vous
promettant des valises de dollars et
beaucoup d'argent à ces arrivées combien
de vous aviez 0 5% de la commission
sirven avait 05 c'est combien pour vous
gênez 45 millions et
45 millions
battant roland dumas ou s'il a voulu
l'épouser quand elle a truqué les
toucher 45 millions on va y venir donc
vous passez du temps et si d'influencé
roland dumas non voilà et alors vous
employez les arguments d'en faire un
moment vous lui dites
il ya ouvriers à lorient qui attendent
leur lettre de licenciement les jo c'est
disons qu'ils n'avaient pas vendu une
frégate de guerre et c'est vrai que le
chantier d'aureilhan était sur le point
de fermer donc vous essayez même de
prendre roland dumas par les sentiments
si on peut dire
et roland dumas donc fini par dire oui
donc la vente a lieu l heure après c'est
plus compliqué mais bon on est là je
sais pas non j'essayerai nathan pour nos
amis d'abord sur le plateau et ensuite
pour téléspectateurs de d'expliquer un
peu l'histoire donc effectivement vous
êtes censé toucher une commission de 2
45 millions
c'est là que le problème je peux prendre
la suite jeu autour de ce problème c'est
que ce réseau elf avait signé un contrat
avec thomson s'entendant bien sûr sur ce
travail avec le réseau elf qui devait
être payé puis le contrat se fait et là
on apprend que les commissions sont
versées parce que vous savez que les
commissions c'est légal le ministère du
budget
credit
suisse est là c'est clair et là on
apprendre que thomson ne veut plus payer
ce réseau af qui est le seul qui a
travaillé et que par contre il invente
région chinois
on sait pas d'où il sort qui a quand
même touché sur les deux contrats parce
qu'avais les frégates d'abord il y avait
les mirage 2000 et les missiles natra
et là on apprend qu'il ya 5 milliard et
demi de commissions qui on est et qui
sont revenus
avant juillet et demi pour faire des
conditions
c'est les
5 milliards et demi de solutions
effectives c'est beaucoup d'argent ça
crie cinq meilleurs ennemis de
commissions qui sont revenus et on sait
on sait pas ou alors le réseau elle a
porté ses fâché a porté plainte donc ils
sont allés en est allé à l'autre et
labora but tu râles de genève où le
réseau elf à gagner et puis un jour il
ya un huissier est allé à la thomson a
besoin de 20 ans il faut payer le réseau
des fermes il avait déjà payé 5 miami
comice accepté d'argent je vous en prie
le real sont des escrocs et je me suis
retourné à fleury merogis voilà
l'histoire
aux gens qui connaissent avec 5
milliards sur l'ensemble la main quand
tu reviens well as m'a fait aimer et à
fleury aussi avec ce soir c'est une
émission comme ça avant que mal à
persuader roland dumas d'accepter de le
vent de chagall écrit serge hayat 189
voilà
ça fait un peu chier ça a aidé des
régies par le sexe
la sauve ce n'est pas de la pole
napoléon sa femme l'a dit ces pays là on
va
exactement
qui contrôle l'un sur cela
cd c'est un ami qui m'a grave et je vais
le lire
je vais dire voiture a commencé à se
battre alors maintenant on à la région
vit c'est vrai comment propos c'est vrai
thiriez que je vous ai menti et j'espère
que vous me pardonnerez mais je vous ai
j'ai menti je le dis dans le début le
juge de touche et blanc tilburg je
mentais donc encore quand je suis venu
sur ce plateau ya un an pour trois
raisons la première c'est que à l'époque
j'avais une défense qui me disait dans
m'a même dit que j'étais un cahier des
films noirs américains pareil parce que
j'avais rien dit pendant cinq mois et
demi extraira parce que quand les hommes
dans cette affaire je peux dire que il
reste pas cinq mois sans salaire série
routier qui avait écrit sa dent forages
en eaux profondes deuxième raison donc
raison on m'avait dit faut rien dire il
faut la fermer et en plus j'aime est un
homme que je protège est bon donc c'est
vrai que j'ai rien dit deuxième raison
j'avais gardé l'argent que j'ai gagné
c'est fugue at je les rendrai chimie à
dix personnages ici je les donnerai à
l'époque alors je les donne et vous
savez pourquoi ben pour qu'aujourd'hui
pour que ma vérité sont entendus
aujourd'hui ma vérité à nouveau elle me
coûte 26 millions cet argent je compte
le récupérer parce que ça prouvera que
j'ai pas volé et que j'ai fait mon
pour les gardes pour toi
savoir c'est qu'à l'époque où roland
dumas croyez que christina les toucher
pognon il a voulu l'épouser donc sa
toile abrite six essais par hape bon
alors là j'ai l'impression de trop
l'argent l'argent l'argent mais la
deuxième raison parce que c'est fait
c'est moi a expliqué parce que je dois
vous connaissez le bouquin mais les gens
ne connaissent pas l'argent vous me
disiez à moi il ya un an et j'ai dit à
tout le monde vers que vous l'aviez
remis à un homme dans l'hôtel à l'hôtel
du rhône à genève j'ai menti la bon en
fait vous l'avez garder parce que
j'allais gagner et je ne l'avais pas dit
à la justice donc ça ne me souviens de
vous dans ma tour des questions de les
gens me souviens de vous n'a pas résonné
sur son coin des yeux dans sa version
série je n'ai pas l'argent
j'allais pas à cette question comment
gérer je n'ai pas l'argent et vous
l'aviez serge est ce qu'on peut là je
crois que j'étais obligé de vous poser
christine deviers joncour la question
qui tue
serre ges que je peux avoir la lumière
de la question qui tue s'il vous plaît
mais bon
ça pouvait rappeler les bons souvenirs
des gens courent alors regardez moi la
question et je vous vois pas mais moi je
vous vois bon alors qu'ils avaient
jusqu'à lors le pognon l'arrivée au
sérieux
alors aujourd'hui il est dans une banque
en suisse gardé par la justice suisse
j'allais dire ok on rallume
ce qu'il faut faire à la télé pour
obtenir des aveux ses terrils j'ai
terrible bien alors hollande ima c'est
bien et c'est mieux ça que le pas totale
oui alors roland dumas donc à l'époque
d'épargné quand vous étiez en prison
vous avez pas balancer c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'était tout le
monde a parlé saut vous ai rien dit
pendant sa vie une femme une femme une
femme amoureuse
les femmes on est solide quand on aime
on aime mais pourquoi alors vous avez
pas parlé à l'époque et alors c'est son
indifférence pendant votre incarcération
qui vous a poussé à vous a poussé
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui vous le
balancer d'humains mais je le balance
pas je ne protège plus je suis allé en
prison et puis là et a plus une nouvelle
mas mes enfants qui le voyait souvent
qu'il voyait tout et tout le temps deux
fois trois fois par semaine on l'a plus
revu plus jamais ma mère qui le voyait
souvent dans ma campagne dans un plus
revu plus de nouvelles plus rien du tout
et puis vous souvenez qu'il a commencé à
dire que j'étais une femme parmi tant
d'autres que j'étais mythomane et puis
bon il est pas arrangé son cas le mec je
crois il vous avez vous avec ses mots
lorsque huit aujourd'hui c'est que
l'appartement organise en fait la partie
retombe l'appartement rue de lille à
l'époque puisque pour moi avait raconté
mais bon aujourd'hui vous dites qu'en
fait c'est un appartement de kikoo de 14
millions à
[Musique]
sarcelles
14 millions et alors vous dites c'est un
quartier un cf qu'il l'a donnée cet
appartement à a dûment négociée d'avoir
aidé à nommer loïk le floch prigent la
tête de l et moi j'étais responsable
économique de 7 à part toi tu vois
comment ça se passe
et l'a14 les mecs qui lui fit d'un
appartement pouvoir fait nommer le
patron
le fond je pense je pense que tout ça ça
n'est pas de vous savez ce que je pense
pas des cas isolés on a mis la pleine
lumière sur moi parce que d'abord je
suis une femme prise dans ce milieu
comme ça il n'y en a pas beaucoup et
vous savez pourquoi parce que on a
trouvé une femme qu'on a voulu prendre
roland dumas qui est aujourd'hui si vous
regardez bien on parle 5 milliard et
demi du commission sur ce marché de
taïwan on a fait beaucoup de bruit
autour de l ski elf nepad affaire elf
elf c'est sait faire le dos et des
institutions de la vème si on fait le
procès de elle sait faire le procès
d'état on peut par le
journal sabah il est plus là bon et puis
et puis ça s'est réduit en peau de
chagrin jusqu'à racing legends coup
roland dumas les actus et et des
chaussures attendez je veux bien qu'on
paie pour ça et on va aller au procès
c'est normal mais moi je veux aussi
qu'on cherche où sont passés les 5
milliard et demi de commissions c'est
clair je dis à nos amis téléspectateurs
qu'on parle de nouveaux francs
parce que ma mère elle croit que ces
anciens francs mais ma mère aussi ses
500 milliards machette fresson milan 0 2
centime
tu te rends compte vous comprenez
pourquoi ça vous ça me donne envie de me
battre si les bruits les plus riches ou
d'être le petit fusible qui va là depuis
deux ans et demi maintenant que je vous
dise tir il a maintenant c'est vrai que
j'en ai jusque là de deux que tout le
monde se limite bien avant pour occulter
les frileux manama oui et non alors ça
et ça ça doit se juger aussi mais le
reste aussi faut le chercher et ça fait
dix ans que cette affaire existe et que
personne n'a ouvert le dossier
aujourd'hui la justice n'a pas bougé
alors maintenant on va la faire bouger
alors on va terminer avec faure est
terminée on va on va parler de votre ami
sirven qui était votre patron alors
aujourd'hui vous dit un peu comme doute
dit de elvis est vivant on vous dit
sirven et vivre vous êtes sûr qu'il est
vivant ce qu'elle vit ce n'est pas sûr
oui on m'a donné on me donne de ses
nouvelles je sais qu'il doit vous parlez
d'un d'un fax enfin de
l'authentifier votre livre mais il n'est
pas authentifiée de vivre non attendez
vous à un champ j'avais dit c'est le
juge le printemps dernier sirven et
détenteur de deux choses qui pourraient
faire sauter 20 fois la république
française donc là où il évolue qu'il y
reste parce que si revenir ainsi parlé
ben non on le mettra en prison et à mon
avis elle susciterait vite et
2,6 commencé à parler c'est vrai que
c'est ennuyeux il ya quand même
la république vont faire sauter les
raisons de ce soir
non il est pas mal mais qu'ils aient
pensé aux philippines vous avez peur de
la mort j'ai fait un contrat sur vous
alors vous savez moi je suis sorti deux
ans puis je suis sorti de fleury d'abord
vous savez quand on sort de prison
quand en sorte de prison déjà je veux
dire qu'on est bien blindé alors j'ai
été menacé quand j'ai commencé en
janvier au mont je venais d'ailleurs
chez vous je commençais à dire les
partis politiques souffler et là j'ai eu
des menaces sérieuses
et la chaire des menaces sérieuses et gg
oui à des signatures de livres a envoyé
des émissaires pour me faire passer les
petits messages comme mon combat était
perdu d'avancé qu'ils feraient mieux
jared des choses comme ça l'utilisation
intimidations et il ya eu un contrat le
rose c'est un vrai qu'entre amis sur moi
on juin dernier au moment où est sorti
le roman où je m'en serve à lancer des
clés que peu de gens ont vu mais qui a
annoncé ça et qu'ils ont que simplement
désigne ici on remarqué mais pas le pas
le public et est en baisse
alors est là et j'ai un contrat sur moi
mais je vais vous dire ça m'a pas
empêché de continuer n'ont
rien fait avec nous c'est je fais ce que
vous voulez
mais si je dois laisser ma place
maurice terre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux